faisons commandeur
de la légion d'honneur dans un salon de
l'elysée un grand honneur rendu antonine
maillet dont les écrits sont
emblématiques de la quasi alors certains
baptisent des cathédrales pire à pierre
comme vos aïeux vous
ces deux pages en pages d'oeuvres en
oeuvre que vous bâtissez la mémoire
l'imaginaire et la langue que le grand
dérangement aurait pu oblitéré déjà
membres de la légion d'honneur
l'acadienne est élevé au rang de
commandeur pour la femme de 92 ans il
s'agit d'une reconnaissance
supplémentaire en france où elle a
étudié et présenté plusieurs de ses
oeuvres l'écrivaine a été la première
non européennes à obtenir le prix
goncourt en 1979 pour son livre pélagie
la charrette
selon la créatrice de la sagouine la
perception qu'ont les français de
l'acadie a beaucoup changé avec les
décennies l'homme a une énorme
transformation autrefois beaucoup de
français ne savaient même pas que la
cades y existait une transformation à
laquelle elle a grandement contribué
mais antonine maillet rappelé que pour
défendre sa langue et sa culture le
combat n'est pas terminé et je tiens à
vous le dire pour que vous soyez
rassurés
qu'aussi longtemps que ma génération
cela
que les gens de mon métier sont là et
qu'elle les gens qui partagent mes
ambitions selon là et bien on ne lâcha
pas nés en vous demandant ce tour et des
nuits vous avez fait réexister
tous ses combats
humble
si déterminé et si essentiel
le consulat français de moncton était
menacé le président l'admet une lettre
que lui a fait parvenir antonine maillet
l'a rapidement convaincu de le préserver
pour elle la france et la quasi doivent
continuer de tisser des liens moi
j'attends beaucoup du plaisir
d'abord j'attends qu'ils viennent en
acadie il a des chances de venir en
acadie parce que nous fêtons ces années
ci on en 24 là on va fêter alors
j'attends du président
qui est un oeil sur l'acadie qui est
distincte celui qu'il aura sur le québec
ou du canada accompagné d'une délégation
venue de chez elle pour recevoir cette
décoration
antonine maillet a certainement
contribué à mettre l'accent sur cette
relation transatlantique
l'impression
en france il ya désormais de symbole de
l'arbre planté en compagnie du président
sur le terrain de l'elysée qui témoins
notamment deux décennies d'efforts pour
mieux permettre à la culture acadienne
de s'enraciner il si rafa lebouvier
oakley radio-canada paris